government says the coronavirus rules
are tough enough
the problem is compliance i've been
looking at the data
and it says something quite different
researchers at ucl asked more than 70
000 people if they were complying with
the rules
more than half said they complied all
the time and 96
said they complied the majority of the
time
that is the highest level since april
now you might wonder if that's the case
why aren't infections falling faster
but although people are complying at
about the same rate they were in the
first lockdown
the virus is stronger and the rules are
looser
you can see what this means in practice
by looking at footfall in retail
destinations
which is tracked in really minut detail
by this company springboard
football plummeted in april slowly
recovered in
uh over the summer and now it's a bit
below the level it was
during the second lockdown now ministers
have
urged people to stay at home and clearly
they're not so
is this non-compliance well
not necessarily because the rules say
shops can stay open
and you can see that in retail parks in
blue where there are more shops open
football is higher basically if you want
to stop people shopping
you need to shut the shops now there is
one rule that isn't being widely
observed and the problem
is that's the most important rule of all
according to that 70 000 person survey i
mentioned earlier
more than a third of people all that
yellow area
don't isolate for 10 days after they've
they've
after they've developed symptoms and 13
all this bit over here don't isolate at
all
they are spreading the virus
but public health experts say what are
we doing about this
where is the free accommodation where is
the increase in statutory sick pay
and where is the enforcement sometimes
it feels like we spend
more time thinking about whether people
get within one meter and a half of each
other
than thinking about this yet if this
rule was followed religiously
we might not need any of the other
restrictions
and this whole debate would be
unnecessary